[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar sustainability today for the lab
tomorrow
i'm christy jewell of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by elaborate and brought to
you by
lab compost to learn more visit
labconco.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have during the presentation to do
so
simply type them into the ask a question
box on the left and click submit
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also use that ask a question box
to let us know if you're having any
technical difficulties
today's webinar is educational and does
offer free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits
i would now like to welcome our speaker
for today
ryan rios vertical marketing manager at
fab congo corporation
for a complete biography on ryan please
visit the biography tab at the top left
of your screen
brian welcome
you may now begin your presentation
welcome to sustainability today for the
lab of tomorrow i am ryan rios co-lead
of the lab congo sustainability
committee
i'm very excited to discuss with you all
today sustainability and its impact on
your lab please comment and post your
questions throughout our discussion
today so that i can address those at the
end and if there's any follow-up our
team will love to hear from you
email us at sustainability labconco.com
every purchase decision you make for
your lab today impacts the story you'll
tell tomorrow
this is because selecting equipment in
the lab environment isn't like other
decisions that we make daily
think of it this way the risk to
purchasing the wrong version of the
iphone isn't going to waste you
thousands in annual energy costs or
increase the chances for lab workers to
one day develop cancer
making sustainable lab equipment
purchases improves workers safety and
efficiency
the environmental impact as well as the
profitability of your lab
today let's review the concept of
sustainability what makes lab equipment
sustainable
so that you know the questions to ask so
that you're sure
you're making decisions today that will
have a lasting impact on your lab
sustainability in the future
let's define sustainability for our
discussion
sustainability is a very complex issue
with many factors to consider as you
look to make the most responsible choice
while this issue of sustainability isn't
new especially in the science industry
we have seen a culture shift globally
more people are aware of these issues
and it's being measured and reinforced
in ways we haven't yet seen as consumers
organizations are now working to address
the complex sustainability issues with
specific targets initiatives and action
items all of this is excellent but it's
placed lab workers in the dark placing
the burden of being a sustainable
purchaser on the consumers themselves
without a framework for how best to make
an impact and the right choice for their
lab
i'm going to simplify sustainability and
focus on qualifying your lab purchases
using the three principles or ps of
sustainability people that is how does
my lab equipment impact people
a sustainable product should improve
their safety and efficiency
most commonly associated with
sustainability and well-known of the
three is planet so what impact does my
product have on the planet labs are
inherently consuming so sustainable lab
product will have a longer life cycle
contain more and consume less
least commonly associated to
sustainability perhaps is profit so we
ask ourselves how do these combine to
improve the overall profitability of my
lab when choosing lab equipment for your
application there are often a million
correct configurations this further
complicates the decision making process
for you so not only has the world tasked
you with being a responsible consumer
the lab has now provided you a million
options for doing so to make the
sustainable decision making process
easier
let's break down these three
sustainability principles for three
types of equipment commonly found in the
lab ventilation any equipment that is
used for the containment of hazardous
vapors or fumes and ventilates air to
washers and water systems so anything
that washes glassware or provides you
with lab-grade water
and then sample preparation as it sounds
so this is any equipment that is used in
the preparation of samples each poses a
unique set of challenges and solutions
that you must consider as you work to
make the most sustainable purchasing
decision so sustainability extends
beyond its impact on the planet to the
people themselves and because of the
high level of potential exposure risk in
the lab and the highly technical and
specific workflows we must factor in the
people themselves into our purchasing
decision ask yourself how can my choice
of ventilated equipment impact people
to improve their safety and efficiency
this is achieved by following the
correct process to selecting your
equipment reviewing these decisions with
all necessary stakeholders early and
throughout the life of your lab design
and looking for built-in safety and
efficiency features new labs must
conduct a comprehensive chemical hygiene
plan and risk assessment per the
authority having jurisdiction and all
the applicable
laws codes and standards even if it
isn't a new lab this is going to define
your materials of construction your
product specifications and mechanical
systems for all of your ventilation
equipment to be sure that you have the
best possible safety for your workers
and it is built to withstand their
application needs of the future and
optimize their workflows moving forward
you want to get everyone on the same
page early and throughout the entire
life of the lab designer project these
decisions must be understood and
evaluated at each step this is to engage
stakeholders who might be separated from
the design process and will lead to the
most sustainable process and solutions
to learn more on sustainable lab
planning and a breakdown of roles and
responsibilities as well as the relevant
sustainable trends and goals for lab
planners please watch solving
sustainability a look inside the lab
for those of us not designing new labs
you'll want to look for built-in safety
and efficiency features so is it
ergonomic by design and does it provide
unobstructed work areas so you'll want
to look for aerodynamic airfoils that
maximize containment and define workable
areas so that users can operate more
safely and with peace of mind also note
a curvature in the design that provides
comfort during long hours of work on
biosafety cabinets you'll want to look
for slots that ensure safe inflow of air
and maximize containment should any
portion of the grill be inadvertently
blocked while the user is working note
the curvature in the design which builds
that user comfort in so they don't have
to buy an additional armrest does it
define workable areas let's take
labconco's exclusive type c1 biosafety
cabinet for example it is the first ever
that can be used in recirculating a mode
for standard microbiological work or it
can be connected to an exhaust system to
function in type b mode for handling
hazardous chemicals unique designs
chemzone is a large clearly defined area
within the enclosure that defines the
safe area for handling chemicals to
ensure the user's safety on fume hoods
look for the aerodynamic curved foil
that allows air to sweep the work
surface openings that pull the inflow
air from under that airfoil it forces
air into non-turbulent streams to
maximize the containment and user safety
note the physical curvature of that foil
so it's not flat like other cells and
that is because it needs to define the
working area for that user so they keep
those chemicals contained in the
interior of the hood and maximize their
safety and they're not setting chemicals
outside of that containment zone on all
models you'll want to look for safety
glass sash that operates quietly and
smoothly it should not obstruct the
workers view and so that they can work
more safely and efficiently cord keeper
slots can allow for workers to use that
full working space really efficiently
and there are no cords that are getting
in their way throughout the process as
you design a new lab or even when you
look to order a
new piece for specialized workflows
consider color coding that equipment per
their application this will help to
reinforce the safe use and proper
operations per your chemical hygiene
plan or risk assessment for that
specific lab next let's move on how do
glassware washers and water systems
impact people in the lab to improve
their time and workflow efficiency if
you've spent any amount of time in the
lab you have used water to hand wash
reusable labware this is because it's
found in almost every activity within
the lab from holding samples to
preparing reagents and buffers and
measuring liquids many of you probably
see washing labware as a mandatory part
of lab life it's inevitable but what
starts as a simple task quickly becomes
time-consuming and messy and an extreme
burden at the end of a long day
particularly when the spaces are shared
or if their application produces a lot
of soil pieces so look for built-in
intelligence and lab grade
configurability and quality labconco
glassware washers feature an operating
system to automate processes and
parameters for daily repetitive tasks
the 5-inch touchscreen display is
user-friendly and provides them with
full control of their washer ask
yourself is it programmable with 10
programs included on lab congo glassware
washers to set lab workers up for
success from day one let's say they only
need to rinse or dry
or they want to choose from common lab
materials or applications such as
plastic or glass or
life science and analytical they can
choose all of these things they could
also select extreme for tough dry-don
contaminants
or eco for light duty these are all
pre-programmed by lab conco for the
specific application needs of the lab
users can easily create and store 200
more custom programs giving them
intuitive control of their washer to
automate cycles freeing more time up for
meaningful tasks ask yourself if it's
configurable and does it support the
many applications of all workers now and
in the future this is why labconco
glassware washers can handle over 5000
configurations of labware and all types
of lab grade water this is to support
the wide variety and robust application
needs of the lab it's built to accept
any of the glassware you might see such
as volumetric flasks or pipettes as well
as test tubes and beakers and dry them
all effectively
in one load saving users valuable time
you might consider under counter
glassware washers similar to what you'd
have at home and wall mounted water
systems these both could be used to save
floor space and free up working counter
space for the users be sure that
accessories and systems are working
together to improve workers efficiency
so does it really have enough options
for the complex workflows in the lab
with the ability to maximize throughput
with its accessories that are tailored
for that glassware washer this includes
the right type of water for their
applications otherwise they may be
wasting unnecessary time on replacements
and maintenance and unnecessary hand
washing let's end our discussion today
on the potential impact on people with
another common workflow of any lab
sample preparation because scientific
measurement is only as good as the
sample preparation that precedes it it's
a key component of many workflows it's
also very very time consuming but as
such an important step in our scientific
analysis
why would we take a risk so ensure that
workers have
built-in intelligence and safety with
the configurability they need for their
workflows with lab grade quality and
accessories you can look for operating
systems to automate sample run
efficiency this will eliminate the
guesswork for users and prevent
excessive run times per batch they'll
enjoy a more efficient use of their
equipment with easy to use touch screen
controls sample monitoring and program
storage and they can stay updated every
step of the way in or out of the lab
with optional email alerts that will
notify them when their endpoint is
reached also look for heat and runtime
programmability to maximize their
throughput with built-in features to
keep analysts and equipment safe this
includes automatic locking mechanisms
and fail safes failsafes will notify the
users when operation or equipment
malfunction to allow the efforts that
they use to produce that sample to be
preserved instead of finding out that
their samples were damaged during their
run and that they need to start all over
so is it configurable to support the
many application needs for all workers
to maximize their throughput labconco's
freeze dry line has ice holding capacity
from 2.5 liters all the way up to 18
liters this allows for multiple runs
without the need to defrost in between
the accessories support samples from
micro leader all the way to liters in
size
the shelf processing areas are up to
over
a thousand square inches and ptfe
coating is available so that you can
freeze dry any type of sample even
corrosive substances providing over 60
interchangeable accessories to
accommodate the widest variety of
applications with simple plug-and-play
intelligence with labcongo's
concentration and evaporation line
you're able to produce a high throughput
of samples efficiency
from low volume to high
and biological or non-biological it
ensures the efficient production of many
small samples and you want to also ask
yourself if accessories and systems are
working together to improve worker
efficiency and is it the right solution
for the complexity of lab workflows and
applications from ventilation all the
way to washers and water and sample
preparation ask yourself if this is the
best possible solution for lab workers
safety and efficiency and their specific
application needs and workflows when
consumers hear sustainability they often
think of some form of environmental
impact but what you may not know is that
we as lab consumers carry a lot more
weight on our shoulders because the lab
unlike the home or the office consume a
substantial amount of natural resources
for example the global research
enterprise which consists of millions of
labs consume on average five to ten
times the energy per square foot of
similar size structures
labs with large process loads or clean
rooms for example can consume as much as
a hundred times the energy of similar
sized structures
so let's discuss how you can make an
impact on the planet with every purchase
sustainable lab products will have
longer life cycles contain more while
consuming less
ventilation products account for a large
portion of total lab energy consumption
in fact one chemical fume hood can use
as much energy as 3.5
homes
every single day
due to the large volume of air
that must be moved through the hood by
the ventilation system
so you're going to want to look for
proven containment
this is why labconco built its airflow
test lab with the ability to control
every single element of the room
from temperature and air quality all the
way to supply air volume and location
all of it from a computer
with the capacity to exhaust air volumes
up to 5600 cfm and the versatility to
test small and large equipment all the
way from 2 feet to 16 feet ducted bench
top and floor mounted hoods
labconco engineering teams create
enhance and precisely test features in
order to gain high performance at lowest
operating cost as measured in cfm and
incoming base velocity for all of our
ventilated equipment
with the greatest versatility in
technology we're able to push our
product development to the limit
let's take a look at an example before
finalizing the design of our high
performance fume hoods
our engineers tried over 50 airfoils
this resulted in a 7 to 10 percent
reduction in energy consumption
compared to flat foils
they tried over 50 baffle combinations
to lower the required average face
velocity needed decrease the resistance
to the in entry air and promote
horizontal air streams maximizing
containment
and two dozen sash handles to ensure
that the airflow was swept into the hood
with minimal turbulence and the slots on
the sash tracks of the corner post
enhanced airflow
another thing that labconco does
differently is that we test our products
to validate our designs throughout the
human body so what i mean by that is
that we test our products with tracer
gas at additional probe locations so for
example at the chest right in that
breathing zone of that operator so that
we can validate that there is no
potential hazards for that user and they
operate at their optimal safety
so we test our products this way to be
absolutely certain that we have
unrivaled containment at the lowest
possible energy use
but don't take our word for it ask your
manufacturers to share their third party
test reports because this attention to
detail in our own product design
allowed our hoods to be tested per the
national institute of health protocol
to an ashrae 110 as manufactured high
performance containment rating of as low
as 0.000
parts per million of tracer gas detected
outside of the hood with a lowest
detectable limit of 0.001
parts per million
choosing ventilation equipment that is
proven to be better by design will not
only result in improved energy
consumption but it will also lead to
longer life cycles
so look for durable construction
features such as led lighting which last
longer and materials to match their
application per their chemical hygiene
plan and risk assessment all of which
are specific to their lab and needs
this will ensure a greater total life
cycle there are also incentives for
making such responsible choices for your
lab so the united states green building
council's leadership in energy and
environmental design or lead
allows you to earn credit for
operational efficiency and longer life
cycle of your products so ask your
manufacturers about percentage of
recycled content which is focused on the
previous content and what that product
is made from
then you're also going to want to ask
them about percentage of recyclable
which focuses on the post-use content
and how much of that will recycle after
the product's useful life
lab conco fume hoods are built with over
40 percent recycled materials
with 70 percent of the materials being
recyclable after its useful life so this
will earn you credits for energy and
atmosphere materials and resources and
innovation and design
the same lead credits can be applied for
our bio safety cabinets which are made
with over
55 percent recycled materials and 95 of
the materials are recyclable after its
useful life
less filter replacements are going to be
required over the life of your products
because you've conducted or referenced a
thorough chemical hygiene plan and risk
assessment specific to your lab to
determine the best possible equipment
solution for your labs needs today and
in the future
do not forget to factor in the cost up
front of filter replacements and
maintenance because over time those
things can add up
because of the large consumption of
water by labs efficiency and
conservation are going to be key
so let's review the impact washers and
water systems may have on the planet
choosing lab-grade systems results in
longer total life cycles better lab
efficiency
and reduce water consumption
think of your home dishwasher or water
filter for your tap water
except for these are going to be much
more robust for all of the flexibility
configurations and sizes needed for the
lab
with washers that are built for purified
water input whereas your home washer is
only able to accept tap water using
quality lab grade water works to extend
the life of all of the products in the
lab
also be sure to look for efficiency
features to improve cleanability such as
dual pumps
so your washers at home only have a
single pump
one to pull water in and wash all your
dishes and the same one that pulls it
all out
in a lab grade washer you're gonna have
two so one
pulls water in and one is going to expel
the water out the reason this is
important is because it will avoid cross
contamination
these units for the lab are also very
very powerful and can get very hot up to
199 degrees fahrenheit
they have other built-in efficiency
features specific to the lab such as
durable construction to withstand harsh
chemicals and hazards and a system to
measure your water conductivity that
allows for the bypass of unnecessary
pure water rinses
as well as hepa filter drying for
particulate free drying and steam
generation for tough dried on
contaminants
lab conco glassware washers are also
going to lead to reduced water
consumption overall and they don't just
save time compared to hand washing
which on average uses 20 gallons to wash
only 30 pieces
systems that you choose should use less
energy and power by design
our glassware washers for example reduce
the consumption by up to 40 percent and
this translates into
potential lead credits and reduce impact
on the environment
so it's built with about 51
recycled materials
and after its useful life 78 of those
materials can be recyclable you are able
to earn lead credits for materials and
resources as well as innovation and
design
my only last note here will be that you
ensure that these plaster washers and
water systems are working together to
maximize the efficiency and total water
consumption
sample preparation is a consuming
workflow that involves a lot of
single-use plastics reusable labware and
many parts and pieces
so you're going to want to look for
longer life cycles and lab grade systems
that consume less energy and are less
harmful by design to the planet
this will result in an extended service
life so how do we maximize our life
cycle of our products and parts
we will do so by
ensuring durable materials of
construction that match the rigorous
applications of the lab
so you want to look for
powder coating and stainless steel
construction
ptfe coating on collector chambers to
resist corrosion
wear resistant quick disconnect drain
hoses
is also going to include
built-in pump production because pump
damage can be very expensive and really
slow you down so you're going to want to
look for a drain line sensor such as lab
concose that detects moisture before it
can damage your pump as a result of
being better by design lab conco freeze
dryers are built with over 47
recycled materials and 85 percent of
those materials can be recycled after
its life believe it or not there are
many perks to choosing lab grade over
your random home system
because the application needs have
dictated our product specifications
these systems are designed for the lab
from the system all the way down to the
parts researchers easily can change from
one methodology to another with a simple
swap of their accessories
it integrates with reusable labware
instead of wasteful single-use plastics
as well as consumes less energy by
design
lifeconco freeze dryers preserve samples
for storage at room temperature
and shelf-stable freeze-dried samples
can eliminate the need for consuming
ultra-low temperature freezers
they're also less harmful on the
exterior air that we breathe with cfc
and hcfc free refrigerants
you can use a cold trap to capture
environmental contaminants instead of
exhausting them into the air or choose a
scroll pump over other popular vacuum
types as they consume 50
less of the power and generate 50
percent less heat it removes all of
those hydrocarbons from potentially
contaminating all the other samples in
the room and they don't require
consumable oils that other pumps use
choosing equipment for the lab that is
better by design results in improved
total life cycle of your products that
contain more and consume less for an
overall greater impact on the planet so
let's now break down how these decisions
may impact the profitability of your lab
the cost to temper air that is required
for this ventilation equipment is
substantial so be sure to look for
energy cost savings in the form of lower
face velocities and the lower air volume
required
as measured in cfm at those incoming
face velocities
you'll want to remember to factor in
filters and replacement costs for the
life of the product up front as they can
add up for washers and water you're
going to want to factor in potential
time and energy savings as well as
longer total life
is it set up to automate efficiency
does it save not only in water
consumption but also hourly wages
similar to the cost of air water costs
vary drastically per location
so ask yourself does it reduce water
consumption by design with the robust
design and materials of construction
needs that you require for your lab use
the lab congo glassware washer
calculator to evaluate your potential
savings and set your own parameters for
days per week in operation number of
pieces washed hourly wages
down to number of rinses and water type
sample preparation systems need to be
lab grade in order to lengthen their
total life cycles and maximize the
efficiency in time and operation
so look for time savings and hourly wage
savings with interchangeable plug and
play accessories and lab grade quality
so that you don't need to purchase
additional products over the life of
equipment look for long processes which
can be automated for example lab conco
freeze dryers can save users up to a
thousand dollars per year versus running
a ult freezer the reliability and total
lifetime of the product is important
less downtime for maintenance or service
equals more throughput and higher profit
margins so let's take a look at one
high-level case study example children's
mercy research institute a research
facility servicing 367
hospital beds with 410
000 square feet of dedicated research
space
they had many goals in mind at the
beginning of this project they wanted to
create a research hub with flexible lab
spaces as they began construction before
much of their research was solidified
they also needed comprehensive gmp
suites for advanced gene and cell
therapies they wanted to maximize their
energy savings with a mechanical system
and lab equipment designed for the best
possible safety at lowest possible
energy use
they needed it to withstand the rigorous
application needs and optimize their
workflows for the lab of the future
the energy savings they received was up
to 56
in cfm by switching from the type b2
biosafety cabinet to lapconco exclusive
type c1 this meant a smaller mechanical
system by volume with lower static
pressure requirements and a dedicated
exhaust system per b2 cabinet no longer
needed they also employed lebconko's
exclusive fume hood with third-party
test ratings of 0.000
parts per million tracer gas detected
outside the hood for
and 140 thousand dollars in energy
savings annually for lab conco fume
hoods at 5000 per unit in cfm savings
times the 28 units
one glassware washer saved them
approximately five thousand three
hundred and ninety nine dollars per year
over hand washing and they were able to
save annually three hundred and nineteen
thousand seventy nine dollars in energy
savings with the ability to maximize
their ultimate exhaust diversity
calculation there's a little bit of
everything in this lab all the way to
non-ventilated products for their
workflow and research
so remember the most sustainable choice
is also the safest and most efficient
for your lab and its users and in the
end it's also the most cost effective
solution making sustainable purchases
for your lab is hard and confusing but
you can make a difference by not only
qualifying your purchases across the
three principles of sustainability but
also choosing manufacturers and products
with embedded sustainability in their
products and operations you can select
the best possible equipment for your lab
workers the environment and dollar
savings
if you have any questions or would like
to learn more about our action plan
please contact us we are interested to
learn more about you and your interests
and how we might support you or if
you're interested in a consultation on
sustainable products we'd love to
discuss your solution email us at
labconco
sustainability.com
thank you so much
thank you ryan for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have any
questions you would like to ask please
do so now just type those questions into
the ask a question box and click submit
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay ryan let's get started we have
quite a few questions already coming in
let's start with this one
why do i need to look for lower face
velocities
and required air volumes at those face
velocities
yeah that's an excellent question thank
you christy
this is a really important question
to ask yourself as you look to select
ventilated equipment any sort of
enclosure that ventilates
into that lab
the reason that this is an
important key to look for is that the
relation there is a relationship between
face velocity exhaust volumes and
operating costs
so in general think of to yourself lower
equals less dollars because not all fume
hoods and biosafety cabinets are made
alike
and every lab is going to have its own
unique ventilation requirements in the
form of air changes per hour so that is
the number of times that we must room or
remove excuse me
that room's volume of air out as it is
specified in the chemical hygiene plan
and the risk assessments for your lab we
do this because we need to ensure that
there's enough air in that room and
we're not starving workers of oxygen
as well as we've properly ventilated it
for their application requirements
and that is to keep the and think of it
this way keeping that air uh safe and of
high quality and so on
now remember in earlier i said one
chemical fume hood consumes as much as
three and a half homes daily
that's because of the large volume of
air that must be moved through that hood
by the ventilation system per hour
so if we look at the average six foot
fume hood operating at a hundred feet
per minute face velocity with the sash
fully open
that's going to consume 70
800
cubic feet of air every single air or
hour
and air is very expensive so
on average that would be eight thousand
two hundred and sixty dollars per year
to operate
but air is very expensive and the cost
to temper it varies drastically per
their location so if if you're in
california where it's 87 degrees
that's going to cost you substantially
less than where i'm at in kansas city
today where it is 47 degrees
so we have to ask ourselves about the
lower face velocities and required air
volumes at those phase velocities in
order to ensure that we are keeping
workers as safe as possible
with the best possible containment and
ensuring
efficiency by the way of lowest possible
energy use
brian thank you our next question and it
is two parts
how do i select the right glassware
washer for my application
and
how does it conserve water compared to
hand washing
that's an excellent question i'm going
to start with the conserving compared to
hand washing so as i mentioned earlier
hand washing 30 pieces of labware takes
about 20 gallons of water
well quality glassware washers should
use less than 13 gallons of water to
wash that same amount of labware
which translates to about 1664
gallons of water per year
but like air water costs vary
drastically per location and will add up
quickly so a quality glassware washer is
going to save your lab money and be much
better on the planet in terms of water
conservation
but they're also going to be for your
application specific needs
many considerations to keep in mind i
would say that in general the because of
labs being so dynamic and fast-paced and
because of workflow and research needs
changing rapidly
you're going to really want to look for
built-in versatility so that the end
users can quickly respond to changes in
standard operating procedures for the
lab
and also that it has the high
performance that it will need to clean
the specialized glassware you might see
from volumetric pipettes or specialty
bottles
to graduated cylinders
thank you ryan and it looks like we have
time for one more question
for sample preparation
what are some of the differences between
lab and home models
yes that's an excellent question because
the general lyophilization concept and
workflow is the same
but the biggest difference there will be
your results
home freeze dryers are usually
all-in-one models
and they're built to preserve berries
you know food things that we eat
the lab freeze dryers are have much
greater capacity and components that are
built to preserve samples for very
important research and testing
much more expensive samples than you
know berries for example it's going to
have additional capacities you have
additional controls such as temperature
controls as well as programmability that
the lab workers are going to need for
such intense workflows that they face
and as well as the flexibility that
they'll inevitably need as their
research evolves in the future
and then while of course that upfront
cost is going to be higher i'll just
point out it'll pay itself back over the
long with or over the life of that
product because of its longer life cycle
and you're going to have scientists that
are and researchers now able to change
their methodologies by simply swapping
out an accessory
versus just having the option of shelves
thank you again ryan for your time today
and for your detailed information on
sustainability today for the lab of
tomorrow
i would like to thank labruz and also
our sponsor lab congo for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i would also like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
we did have a few questions we weren't
able to answer so those
and the ones submitted during our
on-demand period they will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
today's webcast can be viewed on demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you for joining us today
have a great day
you